ก็ผมก็ได้
แท้
สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนมีนักเรียนทุกคนครับวันนี้
สบายดีไหมคะนี่สบายดีครับคุณคิดเพิ่งตื่น
แล้วก็กินข้าวเช้า
อิ่มอิ่มครับอิ่มอิ่มแล้วเดินเนี่ยตอนนี้
จะนอนใหม่ละเขานอนอีก
คนไทยบอกว่าท้องตรงหน้าท้องเป็นหน่อยค่ะ
ของนะหนังเนี่ยตึงตึ่งหนังคานะมันก็
จะปิด
ไร้ยนต์ 5 จรปิดใช่วันเปลี่ยนแล้วมันก็
หลับพอมันหากินใช่ให้หิวนะฮะถ้าหิวถ้าหิว
ก็ต้องไม่เปลี่ยนสีเพราะเราต้องในของกิน
อาก่ากินใช่ของกิน
ใช่ไม่ง่วงไม่นอนด้วย
หิวนอน
พร้อมมันร้องแบบของกว่าคอไม่อยู่ตรงนี้
แล้วกูเอสเสจสบายดีไหมครับสบายดีค่ะแล้ว
ก็กินอาหารเย็นเสร็จแล้วเหมือนกันแล้วทำ
ตื่นเหมือนกันเถอะหนังตาเป็นยังไงครับตอน
นี้หนังตาไม่ปิดเพราะว่ากินขานเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยแล้วก็เดินเดินเดินแล้วก็อาบน้ำซัก
ผ้า
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เก๋ทักผ้ามือก็เลยหนังตาไม่ปิดราคาหรือ
ปิดโอเคโอเคโอเคมาวันนี้ครูเอ๋มีเรื่อง
คันนั้นอ่ะมาถึงวรรณคดีเนาะอันนี้เรื่อง
รามเกียรติ์รามเกียรติ์เป็นวันชนะคดีไหม
เป็นไหมเป็นเนาะเป็นเป็นวรรณคดีไทยใช่ไหม
วรรณคดีไทยนะคะแต่ว่าเรื่องยาว
สั้นๆทั้งขาดตอนนี้วันนี้ก็เห็นเลือกมา
แล้วนี่ล่ะคนนี้เดี๋ยวตัวเองขอแชะปีนะคะ
ได้แต่ก่อนเล่าวันนี้วันอะไรครับครูเอ๋
เฮ้ยเขียนก่อนเกียรติก่อนเคยกับอย่าลืม
ให้ครูตัวใหญ่ๆๆๆอะฤตตามตัวใหญ่แล้วครับ
ได้น่าได้นะ
อ่ะคุยลบอันนี้ก่อนนะคะ
ยก
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันพฤหัสใช่ไหมคะใช่ก็เอา
มาเธอรึ /
เอาวันที่ไหนคะวันที่ไทยหรือวันที่
อเมริกาวันที่บอล
ถ้าคุณนี้พวกมันๆเดียวกันนะวันนี้
ใช่หรอใช่เขาเพราะมันเป็นอย่างเต็มตอน
เช้ามันยังไม่ถึงเที่ยงคืนที่ไทยเป็นวัน
เดียวกันโอเคโอเคๆงั้นก็วันพฤหัสเนาะใช่
ว่าเหมือนกันเช่นถ้าไม่เหมือนกันใช้ครับ
โอเควันพฤหัสบดีนะคะอยู่ FT สมัยไม่
ได้เขียนฮ่าๆๆโอเควันที่เท่าไหร่นะคะวัน
ที่ 9 ครับวันที่ 9 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนครับเดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะอีพ.ศ
2556 ฮาครับปีคศอะไรคะ
2022 ครับตอนนี้อเมริกาเอาเวลาอเมริกานะ
คะไม่ได้ Class กี่โมงแล้วคะตั้งแต่ตอน
นี้ครับที่อเมริกาที่คุณนิดอยู่เนี่ยเวลา
8:00 น 22 นาทีตอนเช้าครับ 8:00  22
นาทีนะคะตอนเช้าตอนเช้ามีพระอาทิตย์นะคะ
นี่ครับมีแดดไม่รู้ว่าเห็นไหมเห็นเห็น
ข้างมากน่าจะร้อนนะใช่ที่นี่หน้าร้อนแล้ว
ครับอากาศมีแดดตั้งแต่ 05:00 น
เนี่ยมีด่านแบบเนี้ยตั้งแต่ตีห้าคูณนิดนะ
ตื่นเช้ามาแล้วก็
8 โมงแล้วหรออ๋อเปล่า 5:00 นคุณนิคต้อง
เปลี่ยนผ้าม่านข้างหลังอ่ะค่ะ
เปลี่ยนสีดำ
แล้วเขาจะนอนได้นั่นน่ะ
ที่ไทยกี่โมงครับตอนนี้ไทยตอนนี้ก็ 20:00
น 20 อีก 2 นาทีค่ะ
กลางคืนกลางคืนครับเป็นเวลากลางคืนนั้นๆ
จับ
ไปฟังวัดได้คดี
วรรณคดีอ่ะก่อนที่จะไปฟังครูอาจารย์แนะนำ
ตัวละครก่อนคุณเพื่อแนะนำนะแนะนำให้นัก
เรียนรู้จักว่ามีใครบ้างมีอะไรบ้างขายค่ะ
อ่าตัวละตัวละครตัวที่ 1 นะคะอ่าเป็นผู้
หญิง
ห่วยมากครับ
คุณนิคนี้ชื่ออะไรครับชื่อมณโฑเออ
ใช่มั้ยชื่อมนต์โทรโทรศัพท์
เฟอร์นิติกแบบผู้ a นะคะๆ
พี่
มลโทร
ขอโทษค่ะนั้นนำเสนอออกผู้ติดโทร
มณโฑนะคะเป็นผู้หญิงก็เรียกว่านางครับ
นั่นก็เลยเป็นนางมณโฑราคา
นางมณโฑเป็นผู้หญิงสวยสวยนะครับดูในรูป
ให้เรื่องนี้จะเกี่ยวกับนางมณโฑ
[เพลง]
สวย
หน้าสวยหน้าเนียนคนไทยก็จะเรียกว่าหน้ามน
ไหมครับหน้าสาวสวยณมนใช่นางมณโฑเลยค่ะเคย
เคยเคยมีคนเรียกใช่ไหมครับเคยเคยถาม
ไม่เป็นนางวันทองเป็นไม่ได้
ค้นพบก็สวยมากคุณนิกลุ่มเอ๋ถูกหวยไม่ได้
20% ของมันกดกูเอกกำลังบอกว่าอันนี้กูเอ
สวยอันนี้นางมณโฑสวยไม่ใช่ที่นั่งเบอร์
โทรที่นี่เลยก็คือ
นางมลโทรดูคิ้วเขาคิดว่าจะเหมือนเหมือน
เหมือนๆวงพระจันทร์น่ะเออ
หิวก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ครับอันนี้สวยเขาบอกผิว
สวยดูคิวเหว
40000 ๆกันนะภูเขา
กูนี้ใช่ไหมถ้าครูเอ๋ใส่หนวดหน้าเหมือน
ผู้ชายนะคะ
แม่เหมือนผู้ชายแต่นางวันทองเนี่ยเขาจะ
สวยนะคะเขียวผิวเหมือน
มุดนมขอเอาชาติน้ำนมสีขาวเหมือนกันแล้ว
มันหมอเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะดูเนียนใช่ไหม
ครับนักเรียนรู้จักนมนะคะเวลาเด็กๆเนี่ย
ก็จะดื่มดื่มนมใช่มั้ยมีวัวมอง
งานคนนี้ดื่มนมเย็นนมเย็นไหมไม่น่าจะไม่
เป็นไรเดี๋ยวเราจะว่าทีหลังได้ตัวละครที่
2 ค่ะคุณนี้อ้ะ
แยกคุณครูรู้ชื่ออะไรคะทศกาล
เก่งมากเพราะคุณนี้กันนับนับหน้า want
ทศกัณฐ์อ่ะมี 10 หน้า
มีหน้าอยู่ 10 หน้า
ตัวสีเขียวเนอะตัวสีเขียวนะคะเป็นเป็น
เป็นยักษ์ใช่ไหมครับเป็นหยาบชายเพราะมี
เยี่ยวแล้วก็มีแค่นี้ตัว
ตัวใหญ่ยักษ์อะๆแข็งแรง
ไม่ใช่หาเก่งแต่นิสัยดีไม่ดีไม่รู้นะไม่
รู้
กลับไปค่ะ
อันนี้เป็นเทพแล้วค่ะคุณนี้ครับอันนี้เรา
เรียกว่าเทพนะคะก็เมื่อกี้ 2 แล้วใช่ไหม
คะ 8 ฉาบนิใครทราบไหมคะคือคนนิดนึกก่อน
น่าจะเป็นพระศิวะหรือเปล่าครับ
เฮอาเก่งมากนะคะเก่งมากชื่อพระศิวะนะคะ
แล้วก็สี่ค่ะนิภรรยาพระศิวะชื่ออะไรคะอัน
นี้เนี่ยคุณนิดคุณนิดไม่รู้ก็คือคุณอิ๊ก
น่ารู้แค่เกี่ยวกับเทพหรือครั
ถ้าเป็นบ้านของใช่ไหมผู้รู้จักแต่ผู้ชาย
ใช่ผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงเนี่ยผู้หญิงคุณน่า
จะรู้จักตัวเอมออกนะคุณนี้จะออกอะไรคุณ
นี้คิดว่าคุณดีรู้จักครับอ่าตีมูรติแค่
นั้น
วันนี้คุณเล็กคุณนิครู้จักถนนชื่อสีลมไหม
รู้จักขับรู้จักอ่ะอันนี้มีมีวัดแต่มีมี
วัดอินเดียเออพรุ่งนี้ครูว่าคนนี้ก็เรียก
แต่ว่าวัดแขกต่อวัดจำชื่อจริงไม่ได้ชื่อ
จริงๆนึกไม่ออกแค่กับมี
มี่เทพองค์เนี่ยอยู่
พระแม่เพราะแม่พ่อแม่อุสุ
อ้อมพ่อแม่ขอพระแม่อุมา
เนอะ
โอเคโอเคโอเค
ช่วยพ่อแม่อุมาอะครับๆโอเคชื่อเพลงคุ้น
คุ้นใช่มั้ยพ่อแม่อุมานะคะหรือบางทีพูดกู
มาเทวีนะแต่คุณอี้กับครูเอ๋จะพูดว่าพระ
แม่อุมานั่งๆรักมีลูกวันนี้มีลูกมาด้วย 8
แต่เรื่องวันนี้ไม่เกี่ยวกับลูกนะคะลูก
มีรูปลูกชายคนเล็กน่าจะเห็นหน้าพิเศษตัน
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
ไข่นะครับเอ่อเออคนที่เป็นครูคนที่รำจะ
ไว้อันที่ใช่เพราะพรมหรือเปล่าไม่ใช่ไม่
ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่พระพรหมท่าน
คิดคะครับพี่พี่เนตรใช่พ.พานเดินลดคูนี้
ก็จะชอบจำสลับ
ครับพิฆเนศครับพระพิฆเนศก็จะเป็นอ่ะใน
เรื่องนี้เราไม่พูดถึงพระพิฆเนศนะคะการจะ
มี 3 พระอิศวรรักสิวะนะพระศิวะก็ได้แล้ว
ก็พระแม่อุมานะคะอ่ะตัวละครตัวปัดตัวต่อ
ไปตัวที่ 5 กูอีกว่าในเนี่ย
อันนี้น่ารักๆเหมือนอ้าๆ
อันนี้
อะไรคะอันนี้คนนี้นี่เองนึกไม่ออกเลยครับ
ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้จักเลยคะรู้จักไม่เคยเห็นมา
ก่อน
แต่งสีเหมือนกันกับคุณนิคเลยเนี่ยสีสี
เขียวเหมือนเสื้อร้านคุณเอ๊ะอันนี้ครู
เอว่าครูนิคหรือเปล่าใช่
ไม่ใช่กูนะโอเคอดีตไม่ใช่คลินิกโอเคอัน
นี้เป็นกบครับ
ออกราคา
อราก็ต่อไป
อ้าวอันนี้หกเจ็ดแปดเก้าเอา 6-9
ฮือ
พูดเหมือนกันค่ะครับอ่าอันนี้เป็นไม่บอก
ชื่อนะคะแต่บอกว่าเรียกว่าอะไรขอโอเคครับ
อันนี้ค่ะเรียกว่าฤาษีใช่ค่ะฤาษีเรื่อง
นี้จะมีฤาษี 4 ตนนะครับ
กบ 1 ตัวนะคะน้ากบ 1 ตัวฤาษี 4 ตนนะคะอ่ะ
แล้วก็
อะไรเอ่ยไม่เอ้อใช่มั้ยไม่รู้จักครับไม่
เคยเห็นญาติกันเกิด
ไม่เคยเห็นเลยนึกไม่ออก
พูดเล่นกูเด็กพูดเล่นให้คุณเล็กจากทำไม
คุณเล็กไม่รู้จักนักเรียนบอกคุณนี้ไปอยู่
ที่ไหนมาทำไมไม่เคยเห็นอะไรแบบแข้วอิ่ม
ค่ะนักเรียนตัวเล็กกำลังจะปิด
อันนี้
บัวครับวัวนะคะวัวในเรื่องนี้จะมีวัวทั้ง
หมด 50 ตัวคุณนิหอ 50 ตัว
ไม่ใช่ 50  500 ก็บอก 500  500 บาทห้า
ร้อยแปด through  a นะไม่วาด 500 ตัวนะ
คุยว่า 1 ตัวพอแล้วนะ
1  1 ตัวก็เหนื่อยแล้วเอก
พอดีได้อย่างงั้นเอก Copy  500 ตัวเลย
ครับห้าร้อยตัวเลยล่ะคนนี้
500 ตัวตรงนี้ใส่ไม่หมดนะคุณเอ๊กซ์จะ
ต้องเหลือตัวเท่านี้นะคะตัวลิงตัวเล็ก
โอเคก็มีวัวนะคะแล้วก็ตอบอ่ะอันนี้เป็น
เท่าไหร่กบเมื่อกี้ 6 ถึงอะไรนะก็คือ 9
ครับหัวก็เป็น 10 น้องค่ะ
แล้วก็ตัวละครโต๊ะตัวต่อไปตัวที่ 11 อ๋อ
อันนี้คุณคนนี้เห็นบ่อยเวลาไปวัดครับค่ะ
ไปวัดแล้วก็จะมีรูปปั้นอันนี้เรียกว่า
หน้ากับมากนักแต่ในเรื่องนี้เนี่ยไม่ใช่
หน้าที่เป็นผู้ชายหาดมีมีผู้ชายผู้หญิงนะ
ครับเป็นหน้าคือเป็นผู้หญิงก็เป็นนางหน้า
อ้ะนะนักดังนั้นคิดถึงไหนนาคเลขนาคีก็ได้
ค่ะนาคี
นาคี
นั่งนักเรียกนาคีโอเคโอเคโอเค
เข้าไปเหตุเป็นผู้หญิงคืนนี้จำไม่ได้
แต่ถ้าเป็นหน้าผู้ชายก็นาคาอ่าครับราคา
ผู้หญิงก็นายขี่แต่ถ้าเป็นหัวหน้าหัวหน้า
เลยน่ะใช่ไหมมีอำนาจ
เรียกว่าพญานาค
นาคีข้อเป็นพญานาคนะคะโอเคครับนะตัวกลับ
ไป
หน้ากรวน
อันนี้เนี่ย
อันนี้เหมือนงูใช่ไหมครับงูงู
สั่งมีหลายๆอย่างคุณ x งู
เขาเรียกว่างูดินค่ะอ๋อโอเคโอเคมีจำนวนงู
ทั้งหมดอยู่นะอะไรนะคะสีดำๆเหมือนดินกับ
ในจำนวนงูทั้งหมดเขาบอกว่างูดินน่ะอยู่
ชั้นล่างสุด
นะหยุดเป็นงูที่
กินอะไรก็ไม่รู้ในดิน
โอเคครับเค้าแบ่งก็แบ่งแบ่งชั้นนะนาค
เนี่ยมันเหมือนงูที่สูงที่สุดข่าวนะเพราะ
ก็มีงูงูดินอยู่ข้างล่างสุด
งานเลยลงมาเลยครับโอเคเราก็รู้จักแล้วรู้
จักโมเดนรู้จักนางนาคีรู้จักวัวนะคะรู้
จักฤาษีให้ร้านนี้ก็เป็นกบครับนะคะอ่าพระ
ศิวะพระแม่อุมานะคะก็อาทศกาลแล้วก็นา
งมณโฑโมครับต้องรู้จักนางมณโฑเพราะเรื่อง
นี้เป็นเรื่องของนางมณโฑ
จะเป็นเรื่องอะไรเกี่ยวกับนางมณโฑครับคุณ
นิคอ่ะเคยได้ยินเขาว่านางมณโฑใช่มั้ยเคย
เคยครับรู้ว่านางมณโฑสวยใช่ไหม
เช้านั่งบนโทรพ่อแม่เป็นใครมาจากไหนแล้ว
ทำไมนางมลโทรมาแต่งงานนี่
แต่งงานกับทศกัณฐ์
อันเนี้ยครูนิคไม่รู้คุณนี้กูเพราะว่านาง
มณโฑ
สวยเหมือนคุณไหม
ขอบคุณ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
นะมันโทรสวยมาก
ผิวหนังมาโทรสวยมากกูเองมีสีดำไม่เห็น
ด้วยกันอ่ะคุณที่เห็นเนี่ยผิวเหมือนกันมี
เรียนเหมือนกันซูมช่วย
โอเคก็กำเนิดนางมณโฑใช่ไหมคะใช่เรื่องมี
อย่างนี้ค่ะคุณนี้ครับเรื่องมีอยู่ว่ามี
ฤาษีฤาษีนะคะฤาษีน่ะฤาษี 4 ตนนะครับพี่
ต้น 4 ตนก็เป็นเพื่อนกันนะคะครับ SP ตอน
นี้ก็อยู่ที่นี่อยู่ในป่าคุยวัดเป็นต้น
ไม้นะคะคุยก็ว่าต้นไม้ไม่เต็มเพราะ Copy
มา
ไม่เป็นไรครับของตัวเอง
เขตเทคโนโลยีไม่เก่งนะคะกูเองอ่ะ
อ้าก็มีฤาษีตนนะคะเขาก็
เขาก็บอกว่านั่งนั่งแล้วก็ไม่รู้คิดอะไร
อ่าอา
สมาทิน้องนะ
แต่ว่าภาษาภาษาหรือสีเค้าเรียกบำเพ็ญตบะ
หมอบำเพ็ญตาบ่า
โอเคอำเพ็ญจะบะกูยากนิดนึงแล้วนักเรียน
บำเพ็ญตบะก็คือนั่งแล้วก็จะมน Hino แล้ว
ก็หายใจเข้าหายใจออกหายใจเข้าออกฉะนั้น
เราบางทีก็เข้าป่าแล้วก็เดินเดินเดินๆนะ
คะ
บทสวด
โอมอะไรไม่ทราบนะคะนี่เขามีบทสวดเขาเรียก
ว่ามนสอบมีมนต์นะคะหรือสีตอนเป็นเพื่อน
กันอยู่ด้วยกันนะคะ
แล้วก็คุณเล็กรู้มั้ยข้างนี้เนี่ยก็มีอัน
นี้มีนิเมะครูเอ
อยู่ไหนอ่ะจริงมากข้างหน้าเขามีคุณนิดนี่
เอาแล้วทำไมวัวมา
นี่ๆที่แอบบ้านหรือสีอยู่ไหนอ๋อกูเออลืม
บอกเอาบ้านบ้านอ่ะเนี้ยเขาไม่เรียกบ้านนะ
คะคนนี้จะคุณนิคอันนี้คุณครูเพราะว่าคุณ
นิคเคยได้ยินบ่อยเขาเขาเรียกว่าอะไรคะเขา
เรียกว่าอาศรม 6 ใช่เลยอาโสกผมก็คือบ้าน
ของฤาษี
รักก็มีมีอาศรมอยู่ 4 หลังฉาบปี๋ตนขอบน่า
รักเนาะเอาเล็กๆแล้วกัน
จะได้เป๊กๆเข้ากันนำต้นไม้ก็ไปแล้ว
ไม่เป็นไรอันนี้ก็จะเห็นว่าเหมือนต้นไม้
เหมือนกัน
ที่นี้น่ะข้างหน้าข้างหน้าอะส่งว่าค่ะคู่
นี้ครับเอาเอาคุณมิคมาไว้ตรงนี้นะคะ
จะเช็คคนนี้เขาไม่เห็นผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวกบกบ
ตอนนี้ก็จะมีสระน้ำ
สนามพระคุณนี้แล้วก็มีกบนะคะกบก็อยู่บนไป
ไปใบบัว
มีดอกบัวครับ
มื้อนี้คุ่คิดเองนะคะมีหรือเปล่าไม่ทราบ
วิธีก็ดีครับจะได้สวยๆเราคิดว่ามีมีมัน
ต้องสวยๆครับถ้าเอาสีค่ะคุณนิคุณนี้เป็น
คนใจดี
คุณนี้กัดคิดว่าคุณนิคใจดีขอขอฉันเกิด
แต่พรุ่งนี้ไม่รู้นะว่าคนอื่นคิดยังไง
วันนี้คิดว่ากูดีใจดีๆคุณคนเดินเดินมา
แล้วก็คิวข้าวไม่มีข้าวกินคุณนิไข้คะให้
ครับถ้าคุณเล็กมีข้าวคนนี้ก็อ่ะเอาไปกิน
อ๋ออ๋อให้
มึงรู้ไหมฤาษีทั้งสี่เนี่ยก็ใจดีเหมือน
ครูนิโอเคเขาเขาให้อะไรกบกินล่ะครับอ่ะ
เขาให้นมค่ะเพราะว่าเขามีแต่นะเอก Copy
มาก่อนซื้อ
ลึกคุยเล่าเร็วไปไหมคะนักเรียนฟังทันนะ
เขามีมูลวัว
อ้าว a ไม่ว่าง
ไม่ใช่ต่ออย่าเอาเรื่องสี
ผิดหนึ่งต้น
ขอโทษนะคะนักเรียนทำผิดค่ะอ่ะ R วัวเนี่ย
หาหัววัว
นั้นแบบเห็นหัวนะครับวัววัววัววัว
500 ตัวใช่ไหมคะคุณ make กลัว 500 ตัว
เนี่ยก็เห็นหรือสี Ten ฤาษีดีเราก็เก่ง
ชอบวัว 500 ตัวน่ะก็จะมาตรงนี้จะมีถ้ามี
เปลี่ยนใช้อันนี้ 4 น้ำตาลแล้วกันค่ะเป็น
อ่าอ่าง
เป็นอ่านแบบนี้
คือใหญ่ๆ
วัวเนี่ยค่ะคุณเอ็กซ์ขอโทษนะคะหรือสี
เหลืองสีออกไปก่อนนะฤาษีกำลังนั่งอยู่มา
นั่งบำเพ็ญตาบาทอยู่รอให้
กูเอกก็เลื่อนดูสิออกนะคะ
เอาไปไม้ไปด้วย
อันนี้เลื่อนมาหน่อยอันเล็กๆหน่อยนะกัน
อ่ะอ้าวแล้วก็วัว
วัวนะคุณมีขาวัวเขาก็จะมามาๆมาที่ที่ฤาษี
นะคะถามแล้วเขาก็จะมาให้นมหาครับนม
น่าจะ 4 นี้เนาะสี่ห้าใช่ๆนะกูเองไม่รู้
สีอะไรอ่ะน้องเขาขาวๆนักเรียนๆครับ
วัวเขาก็จะให้นมคุ้งในอ่านนมใหญ่ตัวใหญ่
ใช่ไหมครับเลยเพราะว่านมอันนี้ก็คือฤาษี
จะกินได้เช้ากลางวันเย็นอ๋ออ๋อแล้วมี 4
ตนใช่ไหมครับฤาษีให้งั้นเนี่ยกลัว 1 ตัว
ไม่พอใช่ไหมคะก็ต้องวัวหลายๆตัวก็มาแล้ว
ก็แม่วัวเราบอกแม่วัวมาให้นมนะฮะให้นม
แล้วก็ไป
ไปๆ
เอาก็บ๊ายบาย 5 ไปๆเล็กๆไปก่อนเก็บตรงนี้
ครับ
โอเค
ใจดีหรอเคยทีใจดี
ฤาษี Tank  4 ตอนเนี่ยคนนี้เขาก็ดื่มนม
วัวตัดดื่มนมวัวทุกวันนะคะแต่ว่าที่กูเอง
บอกว่าหรือเสียใจดีเพราะว่ากบเนี่ยก็ขึ้น
มา
คุณนิคนะคะพี่
กบกบครับไม่ใช่คลินิก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
กกรถขึ้นมาแล้วก็
นมนม
อยากกินนม
[เพลง]
กบไม่กินกบไม่กินแมลงเออก็มีแมลงภู่มาแรง
ต้มอบชอบใช้ลิ้น
จะเห็นโอ้โหลิ้นยาว
ใกล้กบลิ้นเสียง
แป๊บเดียว
ใช่
ก็กดว่าเขาฤาษีนะเข้าใจดีเหมือนคนนี้ค่ะ
คนนี้เขาก็ให้ให้ชมกบกินทุกวันก็จะมีใบ
ไม้มาต่อมิแม่แล้วก็เอานมเนี่ยใส่ใช่ไหม
คือ 4 กับไอ้นมกบกินมาหากบกินมีทุกวันกิน
อิ่มตลกไป
อีกไม่เอาลิ้นออก
ลงไปนอนในน้ำต่ออิ่มแล้วอิ่มแล้วก็จงไปใน
น้ำตาปิดเป็นนอนตอนนี้
อนุกูลได้ปลื้มตาแล้วนะ
วันนี้แข็งตาตาเล็กๆกับผู้หญิงเติบโตแล้ว
ฮ่าๆๆ
ขอขับแล้วก็ลงไปเลยน้ำโอเคชายค่ะ
แบบนี้น้องไม่มีปัญหาอะไรน้อง
จนกระทั่งวันนึงคุณนิคครับ
นิมีนางนาคีนี่ครับนาคีขึ้นมา
แล้วนาคีน่ะก็ไปเจอ 7 เจอกับงูดิน
ถ้า
เจอกัน
นางนาคีมาแล้วก็เจอกับงูดินช่า
แล้วแสดงนาคีกับงูดิน
เหมือนโรมีโอกับจูเรียสเลยค่ะพรุ่งนี้
เกิดอะไรขึ้นอ๊อ
[เพลง]
นะ
คะผู้ชายอาจจะไม่ได้เรียนหนังสือขุดดิน
น้ำผู้หญิงก็เรียนหนังสือมากๆ
รักกันรัก
อันนี้ไม่ใช่คนอันนี้เป็นเป็นขี้ราคา
[เพลง]
ขี่หนักๆนะขี่ก็เป็นงูชั้นสูง
งูดินก็เป็นงูชั้นข้างล่างก็ประมาณนี้คน
ละข้อแล้วว่าคนละชั้นคนละวันนัดใช่ไหม
ครับใช่ค่ะรักกันได้ไหมอ่ะได้ก็คนเรารัก
กันน่ะไม่ต้องมีวันนะไม่ต้องมีฉันก็รักๆ
เถอะ
2022 เนาะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ทำไมอ่ะจะจัดก็รักอ่าทำไมไม่สนใจอ่ะผู้
แปลว่ามึงก่อนเมื่อก่อนมันไม่ได้คุณ x
อ๋อโอเคโอเคก่อนไม่ได้เพราะงูดินกับน้อง
กินกันต้องชั้นเดียวกันใช่ไหมครับ
2 ของ 2 ตัวเนาะสองสามคนรักกันนะคะกอด
กันนะคะซึ่ง
ฤาษีอ่ะคุยขอดูสีมั้ยคือสีสักหนึ่งแล้ว
กันนะคะ
ฤาษีน่ะเขาก็เดินมาคุยไม่ได้ว่าหรือสิ่ง
เดิมนะคะเอาสีมานั่งกินสีอ่ะมีมีมนต์ก็
ปุ๊บ
มาอยู่ตรงนี้
อีกวันก็ไม่ใส่ 4
โอเคลิปสีกับจริงๆสีต้องเดินมากลับก็เห็น
เห็นมีคนนี้ถ้าคุณก็เห็น
นาคีกับหมูดินรักกันนะๆสอดการอยู่
คุณนิ
ฮัลโหลดีก็ไป
คนนี้จะคนนี้จะแอบสมมติอันนี้คุณนี้แขน
เป็นต้นไม้มัน
แอบดูมีอะไรแล้วก็ไปพรุ่งนี้จะอยู่ที่นี่
อันนี้ต้นไม้
อันนี้คุณนี้ก็จะอยู่ที่นี่แล้วก็จะใช่
แอบดูเอาแบบนี้พอแล้ว
มีอะไร
แอบดู
การ์ดเดบ
แอบดูเนี่ยแอบดูตาจะเจ็บนะคะ
ตัวนี้เจอแต่แอบดูคนรักกันจะ
เปิดหน้า 8 คุณนิคที่นี่เป็นบริเวณใกล้ๆ
กับ
ผสมข่าวเป็นป่าเป็นป่าแล้วไม่ใช่ตรงนี้
เป็นป่าแต่ว่ามันใกล้กับอาศรม
ฤาษีก็เลยบอกว่า
น้าคี
นาคีนคีกลับบ้านไป
กับงูดินไม่ดีขอ
วันนะไม่เท่ากันครับค่า
ราคีต้องรักกับราคาเท่ากัน
นาคีงูเด่นรักกันไม่ได้
ไม่ดีใหมถามคิดดีๆกลับบ้าน
พี่นิกแพทย์คุณนี้คิดว่านาคีกับหัวดิน
กำลังรักกันกอดนี้ก็
ได้ยินนะคีย์ทำอย่างนี้ไม่ดีตกใจเลยตกใจ
ครับตกใจแล้วเอ๊ยมาบอกมาพูดทำไม
เขาคิดว่าไม่มีใครเห็นเออครับมีคนเห็นคิด
ว่าอายไหมอายสิๆครับ
มองใครไม่ได้แล้วคิดว่าอายด้วยโกรธด้วยนะ
ครับกับ
งูดินก็กูดินก็ mood ดินนี่ไปไหนคราวนี้
ไป
นาคีนาคีก็หนีไปนะๆหนีไปอะหรือสีออกนะคะ
ก็หนีไปแต่กำลังหนีหนี้กลับบ้านเขาแบบนี้
ลงน้ำอือถ้าชอบนี้น้ำ
หนีไปนาคีหนีลงน้ำ
แต่คุณนิคกำลังหนีลงน้ำนะ
ลงน้ำครับ
นี่ลงน้ำเสร็จเขาก็จะแบบโกรธไงโหลดแป๊บ
เนี่ยอายด้วยแล้วก็คิดท่าฤาษีไปบอกพ่อ
บอกพ่อเนี่ยเขาจะอายมาก
ขึ้นมาที่นี่
นาขี้น่ะ
[เพลง]
เอก Copy
มาที่นี่
ตอนฤาษีไม่อยู่ครับ
นาคีก็มาที่นี่แม่แบบ
มา
ฤาษีไม่อยู่นะคะมี 4 สีไปไหนไม่รู้จะสี
ออกไปให้หมดนะที่บ้านไม่ต้องไป
เป็นสีไม่อยู่อ่ะหรือ 4 คือสีไม่อยู่นาคี
ก็คิดแล้วก็อายใช่ไหมหรือสีรู้ฉันรักกับ
งูดินขับนาคีก็มาที่นี่เลยคุณนี้แล้วก็
เรามาทำอะไร
มาพ่นผิดคุยให้เป็นสีแดงแล้วกันข้าว
อ๋อ
พ่นพิษใส่นมไปนมใส่นมนะคะใส่นมนะคะคิดว่า
ตอนหรือสีนอนหรือสีไม่อยู่กูอาจจะไม่ได้
แล้วเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยกบเห็นค่าคุณนิกบตาโต
ไงและกบกะใช่ๆกบตาโตกบเห็นนาคีน่ะพ่นพิษ
ใส่เสร็จนาคีก็ไปชอบ
หน้าขี่ไปไปหนีไปหน้า
พอดีคิดเดี๋ยวฤาษีมาเล่นสีมา
สีมา
[เพลง]
แล้วก็กินนมกินนมจะเป็นยังไงให้คุณนี้กิน
นมแล้วก็เตะ
เขามันอิฐฉาบใช่ๆกบก็เลยนะพูดไม่ได้ใช่
ไหมซึ่งผลก็เลย
กระโดดลงไปค่ะ Shop กระโดดลงไปในนมกินกิน
ๆๆปายขอ
ตาย
ตอนเช้าฤาษีมาเสร็จหรือสิเอ้ย
กบทำไมกินนมมากๆป่ะ
กินยาลดท้องท้องมันแน่นท้องมันอาจจะแดก
ท้องแตกตายหรือเปล่าคุณฤาษีคิดแบบนั้นมี
แต่จริงๆไม่ใช่ her แปลฤาษีก็ใจดีคนเล็ก
มันเสียใจดีดีก็เลยโอมสวดมนต์แล้วก็มีไฟ
มีไฟแล้วก็อยากจะรู้ทำไมกินมากๆตายครับ
ฤาษีก็เลยทำให้
ไม่ใช่
re4 ก็เลยนี่ค่ะ
ทำให้กบน่ะไม่เป็นกบแล้ว
ทำให้กบเป็นผู้หญิง
เป็นผู้หญิงสวย
ขึ้นมาจากไปสอบเป็นนางมนมาโกะเปลี่ยนเป็น
ผู้หญิงสวยกบตายอ้ะถามแล้วก็ให้พาว่า
กอล์ฟ
อ่ะกบทำไมกินนมจนตาย
กบก็เลยบอกว่าไม่ได้กินจนตายเพราะกบพูด
ไม่ได้เมื่อก่อนเป็นกบครั้งมีนาคีมาใส่
พิษงูพูดไม่ได้กบก็ได้กินให้ตายเปรย์สีจะ
ได้เห็นว่านมกินไม่ได้เพราะมันมีพิษพ่าย
โอ้วฤาษีก็โอกบนิสัยดีใช่ไหมถามก็เป็นคน
ละนิสัยดีแต่คนนี้คะ
เป็นผู้หญิงอยู่กับฤาษีได้ไหมคะไม่ได้
ครับไม่ได้มีสีก็เลยทำยังไงดีหรือสี่ก็
เลยผ้านะผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็ได้ให้ชื่อว่ามณโฑ
นมนะคะเป็นกบฮะมันโทรแล้วก็เลยเอาไปฝาก
ไว้ที่
อยู่
ข้างศิวะให้นางมณโฑอยู่กับพระศิวะและพระ
กุมาหาแมวมาที่ช็อปค่ะถ้าให้ไปอยู่กับข้า
สิวะกับเขาแม่อุมาพระแม่อุมาน่ะเห็นมณโฑ
แล้วก็ชอบมากครับก็รัก
อะไรสอนสอนให้มณโฑเก่งๆนะพระแม่อุมาเก่ง
อะไรก็สอนมณโฑเก่งใกล้ๆกัน
นะคะแล้วสุดท้ายก็เลยได้ไปแต่งงานกับ
ทศกัณฐ์เออโอเคครับโอนเลยเวลาไปแล้วน่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรแต่ก็วันนี้ก็รู้
เรื่องเกี่ยวกับนางมณโฑคุณนิดเนี่ยไม่เคย
รู้ว่านางมณโฑ
เกิดยังไงอ่ะนะครับเป็นเรื่องที่น่าสนใจ
ครับอาจเกิดจากกบเกิดจากกบ
ชื่อ next
ไม่ใช่นะคะเดี๋ยวผมจะเป็นศพ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เป็นกบจากๆภาษาไทยได้กตัญญูครับถ้าพอใจดี
ครับเพราะว่าฤาษีช่วยก็เลยช่วยหรือสิไม่
ให้ฤๅษีตายนะค่ะโอเคค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็
รู้จักนางมณโฑแล้วแล้วนะโตจะเป็นใครก็ติด
ตามไปเรื่อยๆนะครับใช่ๆคลิปนี้ครูเอ๋กับ
คนนี้ไปก่อนแล้วก็ไปแล้วโอเคได้ครับไว้
เจอกันใหม่ครับครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะวันนี้ครับไม่ว่างครับอ่า